- Les bombardiers d'eau canadair
sont littéralement les avions-
pompiers les plus  les plus céls
du monde.
En 1963 apparaît le CL-215.
- Surnom- Surnommé l'avion pomp.
- Et 46 ans plus tard, en 2009,
Bombardier commence
la production du CL-415.
Et voilà que l'avionneur
canadien De Havilland lance
son nouvel appareil, le DHC-515.
Il peut déverser plus de 6
litres d'eau en 12 secondes.
Six pays européens, dont
la France, la Grèce et l'Italie,
ont déjà officialisé
leurs commandes.
JEAN-PHILIPPE CÔTÉ, v.-p.
programme De Havilland Canada
- Nous relançons la production,
la cadence va être plus basse
au début, donc on planifie
livrer le premier avion en 2026.
- Et il faut dire que
son arrivée sur le marché
tombe à point : j point : j pois
son histoire l'Europe n'a connu
autant de feux de forêt.
Le président français,
Emmanuel Macron, en a même fait
la publicité. Il veut acheter
plus d'avions de type canadair.
EMMANUEL MACRON,
président de la France- On a 12.
En permanence, on en a 10 à 11
qui sont utilisés. C'est inédit.
Est-ce qu'il faut en avoir
davantage? La réponse, de
manière à peu près sûre : oui!
- Malgré tout, la pression est
forte pour livrer les appareils
à temps.
JOHN GRADEK, chargé de cours
en aviation, Université McGill
- Le problème, c'est vraiment
l'échéance. On a besoin
de 500 personnes du côté
de la production à Calgary
pour construire l'appareil
et on a à peine une dizaine
ou une quinzaine de personnes à
l'instant même qui sont capables
de travailler sur
- Même si le DHC-515 sera
principalement assemblé
à Calgary, en Alberta, sa
construction devrait bénéficier
à un ensemble de fournisseurs
et créer des emplois à travers
le pays, selon Aéro Montréal.
SUZANNE BENOÎT, PDG,
tréal
- Ce sont des avions qui sont
motorisés, avec des moteurs
de Pratt & Whitney Canada,
fabriqués à Longueuil.
Les moteurs d'avion représentent
en termes de valeur sur un avion
25 % du prix.
- Dans tous les cas,
les bombardiers d'eau de
De Havilland semblent répondre
à une demande de plus en pl
forte par leur efficacité dans
la lutte contre les incendies.
Ici Gabrielle Proulx,
Radio-Canada, M